el paso de la tormenta a yunís con
vientos de hasta casi 200 kilómetros por
hora deja hasta el momento víctimas
mortales heridos daños en la
infraestructura de cientos de viviendas
de edificios y caos en el transporte al
menos el 20 por ciento de los vuelos del
aeropuerto registró el más grande de
londres y uno de los principales de
europa tuvieron que ser cancelados se
calcula que al menos 430 vuelos en todo
el país también fueron cancelados o
reprogramados también hubo caos en los
servicios de trenes especialmente en el
sur de inglaterra y en galés se reporta
que 200.000 viviendas están sin luz a
esta hora los bomberos de londres
tuvieron que declarar la emergencia por
la cantidad de llamadas que recibieron
pidiendo ayuda entre las 10 de la mañana
y la una y 30 de la tarde recibieron 550
llamadas que es el número que reciben en
un período de 24 horas también una parte
desde el techo del auto que es un
coliseo famoso porque se realizan
conciertos se cayó y mil personas
tuvieron que ser evacuadas por la
inestabilidad del durante este fin de
semana se mantiene la alerta aquí en el
reino unido-